joining us now from the White House is I
assume the White House is the president
of United States mr. president thank you
for taking the time we really appreciate
you joining us hi Sean
thank you all right a lot of breaking
news tonight and you haven't really
talked at length in an interview about a
lot of issues let me start with this
issue of the Ukraine I don't know if you
were following the top of the show or
John Solomon's new report or that both
Catherine Herridge and Sarah Carter are
reporting tonight we now have text
messages from Peter struck and Lisa page
never before seen discussing recruiting
White House sources to spy on you take
it in any order you like well I think
it's incredible when you hear it these
are great reporters all three and when
you have them on your trail that's a
problem these are people that should be
getting Pulitzer is not the ones that
got the Pulitzer is they got everything
wrong if you listen to them they got
everything wrong go back and read some
of their early and mid articles they
didn't have a clue what was going on and
they went Pulitzer Prizes these are the
ones that should be winning
it sounds like big stuff it sounds like
a very interesting with Ukraine I just
spoke to the new president a little
while ago two days ago and congratulated
him on a credible race - incredible run
and big surprise victory got 75 percent
of the vote but that sounds like big big
stuff I'm not surprised
mr. president the Ukraine is offering
this evidence to the United States would
would you like the United States with
all this talk about collusion they're
saying they colluded on behalf of
Hillary Clinton's campaign in 2016 does
America need to see that information
especially in light of all that the
attacks against you on collusion well I
think we do and frankly we have a great
new Attorney General has done an
unbelievable job at a very short period
of time and he's very smart and he's
very tough and I would certainly defer
to him but I would imagine he'd want to
see this so people have been saying just
this whole the concept of Ukraine
they've been talking about it actually
for a long time you know that and
I would certainly defer to the Attorney
General and we'll see what he says about
it he calls them straight that's one
thing I can tell you mr. president our
own catherine herridge investigative
reporter Sarah Carter big breaking news
tonight Senate Republican chairman
submitted a letter Thursday to the
Department of Justice the Attorney
General we have new text from November
of 2016
from struck and paid showing the pair
had discussed attempts to recruit
sources from within your White House to
spy on your administration and reveal
that they had one particular contact
within the White House the vice
president's chief of staff whose wife
was working as an analyst for struck on
the FBI investigation in a Hillary's
private server have you heard this
report tonight sir I just heard it a
little while ago and frankly it's very
disconcerting have you if you look at
what's been happening they were the same
two the two lovers that decided to use
the FBI server instead of their private
so they didn't get cost these two were
these two were beauties no doubt about
it they were going hog-wild to find
something about the administration which
obviously was in there we have nothing
to do with the Russia except that we've
been tougher on Russia than any
administration in 50 years a lot tougher
than Obama but these were the two that
talked about the insurance power just in
case Hillary Clinton loses if she loses
we've got an insurance policy well that
was the insurance policy now she lost
and now they're trying to infiltrate the
administration to really it's a coup
with spying it's everything that you
could imagine it's hard to believe in
this country that we would have had that
I don't know if you remember a long time
ago very early on I used the word
wiretap and I put it in quotes meaning
surveillance spying you can sort of say
whatever you want but that was a long
time ago and I've never seen anything
like blow up like you've never seen now
I understand why because they thought
two years ago when I said that just on a
little bit of a hunch and a little bit
of wisdom maybe they it
because they thought maybe I was wise to
him where they were caught and that's
why because if they were doing anything
wrong it would have just gotten by
nobody would have cared about it it was
pretty insignificant I thought when I
said it and that's pretty amazing so you
see now they're in trying to infiltrate
the White House this is long after the
election it's a disgrace and again
hopefully the Attorney General will do
what's right and I really believe he
will
mr. president the Attorney General
actually used the word spying on your
campaign we know of Stephon helper and
his contacts that he made with
Papadopoulos and Carter Paige and Sam
Clovis we know about the FISA warrant as
the Grassley grand memo said the bulk of
information in the application was the
Clinton bought and paid for Russian of
all things dossier ignored by the Muller
report which will ask you about in a
second here but those are two specific
incidents of attempts to get into your
campaign your reaction to all that well
I think they made many attempts and then
you see the lying and you see the
leaking and you see Comey lied to
Congress nothing happens you see him
leaking nothing happens and this is
leaking classified information this is
leaking really big stuff I remember the
young sailor in fact I helped him out
with his family since also unfairly
treated as you know but I remember he
had confidential information which is a
much much lower standard than classified
and they put him in jail for a long time
they took away his life and then you
look at what Hillary Clinton did with
33,000 emails and hundreds of thousands
of text messages or emails going through
the Weiner server or computer hundreds
of thousands of which many were
classified and nothing happens to her
and yet they put a young sailor on for
doing something innocent showing his
mother and his friend what the desk
looked like the desk and a 40 year old
submarine I think Russia and China would
I had that picture many years ago
so it's really a double-standard like
you've never seen very very unfair but
hopefully that will change I think that
will be changing
mr. president closed-door testimony
recently revealed struck and page that
they were laughing at the idea that the
Hillary investigation was a real
investigation and that it went directly
into Loretta Lynch's office which now
raises a whole new set of other
questions and they were confident about
that and it was struck that did the
interview with Hillary
uncharacteristically frankly
unprecedented allowed to other people in
that interview while she was being
interviewed in an investigation Comey of
course exonerated her but he even
acknowledged top-secret classified
information on that server I did
disagree with you at the time you after
the election were basically saying let
bygones be bygones let's not go down
this road do you regret saying that and
do you think now if we really are to get
to the bottom and the truth that has to
also include Hillary Clinton the email
server which would be an underlying
crime and obstruction which everyone in
the media seems to care about the intent
behind the 33,000 subpoenaed emails
deleted bleach pit hammers SIM cards no
I don't regret saying it when I won they
were all saying lock her up lock her up
and I said no no let's get on with life
that was different it was like right
after the election you want to get a new
page and turn turn over a new leaf and I
said let's get on with it let's you know
build up the economy which by the way is
doing record business I'm so proud of
the economy we're doing numbers that
nobody's ever believed probably the best
economy we've ever had best unemployment
numbers we've ever had it's been
incredible but I said let's get on with
our life let's forget about the past but
now what happened is fairly shortly
after that great evening they started
coming at us with the insurance policy
and everything they did were so
dishonest and then we really started
looking into a lot of things like her
deleted emails and acid-washed emails
which is unheard of because of the
expense of doing it
and how she got away with it how her
lawyer
got away with it how all of these things
happened don't forget when they
interviewed her that was on July 4th
weekend it was very very late into the
July 4th weekend they asked their
questions they didn't have a
stenographer they didn't have anybody
swear her in they didn't have a tape
recorder they just walked in ask for
some questions and that was fine in the
meantime look at what she's done how
she's destroyed the lives of people that
were on our campaign she's destroyed
their lives in the DNC and frankly when
the FBI went into the DNC the DNC told
them to get the hell out of here think
of that they told that to the FBI and
they wouldn't give them the server I
want to find out what's on that sir but
the DNC server because that's the big
thing nobody's seen that sir be at the
FBI didn't see it and these are the top
people at the FBI where you had absolute
dirty cops
these were dirty cops now the FBI I know
FBI guys these are the best in the world
but the people need to get Comey and
McCabe and struck in Page and all of
these people the lawyer who admitted
frankly how crooked things were I mean
the when that testimony comes out it's
already come out partially when that
testimony comes out from the attorney
for the FBI you'll see so I really say
now we have to get down because this was
a coup this was an attempted overthrow
of the United States government we had
people coming out to vote from all over
this country that are in love with what
we're doing it's called make America
great again that's what we've done and
we're doing and this was an overthrow
and it's a disgraceful thing and I don't
I think it's far bigger than Watergate
I think it's possibly the biggest
scandal in political history in this
country maybe beyond political so I
think that a lot of things are being
learned right now just like you just
mentioned just a few moments ago again
with strucken page these are sick people
these are sick sick people you know so
let's see what happens with McCabe and
Co me and Brennan and clapper they were
in the act and let's see what
and let's see how high it goes up
because it's inconceivable when it goes
to clap or Brennan call me these people
I would imagine that some other people
maybe a little bit higher up also knew
about it maybe a lot higher up you
mentioned I mentioned now struck in
Paige independently and their
conversations Peter struck had said
about the collusion there's no there
there
Lisa Paige closed-door testimony
actually said after the nine-month FBI
investigation they had no evidence of
anything with you and your campaign in
Russia that's before the appointment of
Muller we also had the house Intel
committee report that's to no collusion
than the Senate bipartisan committee and
now the rock Muller reporters you said
Oh any news no obstruction no collusion
well I want you what is your full
reaction to the Muller report well it
was as I called him 13 angry Democrats
they were supplanted by five more five
more were added and you got up to 18 19
20 they're all Democrats many of them
made major contributions to the Hillary
Clinton campaign and they said one of
them was one of the top people at the
Clinton Foundation jeanne ray
then you had Weissman you had some bad
bad bad people no friends of Trump I had
no friends it was like a one-sided
witch-hunt as I called it and you know
Bob Muller I turned him down
to run the FBI the next day he was
appointed to be the head of this this
special Council as they call it it's
really a much tougher word than that but
I won't use it and it was a terrible
thing he was conflicted for that for
that reason he also was conflicted
because of the fact that Co me and him
are best friends so if not best very
close to best but I would say best
friends you look at pictures of the two
of them in the past we had a nasty
business transaction the two of us I had
a nasty transaction with him and then
all of a sudden he said my prosecutor
very
very unfair and with all of that and 35
million dollars spent think of that over
2 years ruining lives of people ruining
their lives people going out of business
because they couldn't afford lawyers
that's just unbelievable what happened
how bad it was I can't even tell you how
bad it was nobody nobody knows what how
people suffered great people that came
to Washington they came to DC to to set
the world in a very positive way on fire
they wanted to clean things up and do a
great job and all of a sudden they're
testifying on nonsense and it's really
shaping you know with all of the things
you've heard nothing had to do with the
campaign nothing had to do with Russia
collusion but the bottom line is with a
group of very serious trumpeters a group
of I call him angry Democrats somebody
who is very conflicted at the top know
collusion and also know obstruction
because the statement was made and the
Attorney General you no wonder stood it
very well and he read it and he made a
decision right on the spot
no obstruction so yet no collusion no
obstruction 35 million dollars spent and
unlimited manpower woman power and is
nothing nothing and it was a very bad
two years for this country but what has
happened is we found everything going in
the opposite direction and I think now
it's turning unbelievable the tables
have turned and you're seeing things
come out like you just like you just
noticed and it's I think it's going to
be very interesting it's very important
for the country to now find out how that
whole thing started and in all fairness
to Bob Muller it started long before he
was appointed this was going on long
before that you understand the first
lady and I came down on the escalator on
June 16th and it started very shortly
after that it was a disgrace president
we expect a lot more coming out in the
days weeks and even months ahead we know
at least 53
more closed-door the testimony
closed-door of many of these players
that will be released we know that the
inspector general he now will have his
report we expect sometime in perhaps it
may likely in may where he will he's
been investigating the FISA abuse issue
and then of course we have Hoover on
leaking and whatever his report
ultimately ends up becoming we know that
you know there's there's a lot of
information and then the issue you have
the last time I talked to you about a
month ago you said you would declassify
the FISA applications you would
declassify gang of eight material 302
material if the Grassley Graham Nunez
memos are correct in the bulk of
information in the FISA applications
were even as the New York Times
suggested this week may have been
misinformation from the Russians that
Hillary bought and paid for that was
disseminated to the media and the
American people before that election you
know what would that mean to you well
first of all I was very impressed that
the New York Times did that because that
was the first good glimpse that maybe
mainstream is going to pick up the
greatest political scandal of in the
history of our country again bigger than
Watergate because it means so much this
was a coup this wasn't stealing
information from an office in the
Watergate apartments this was an
attempted coup and it's in concealing a
third world country and inconceivable
and I have to say that I think a lot of
informations coming out and is coming
out fast much faster than anybody would
have thought and there are a lot of
people very nervous about things that
are going on and I will say that I G the
inspector general horowitz he other than
his conclusion where he said no bias but
he meant that in a different way than
you would think he gave a great report
last time and I really hope that he's
going to give it I don't know him he was
appointed by Obama that bothers me a
little bit but I think he's everything I
can see he's really an honorable guy and
I think he
knows how big this is I think he knows
how big this is and if he is as
honorable as he's supposed to be the IG
report coming out in three or four weeks
from what I hear is going to be and
should be and almost has to be a
blockbuster because he has access to
information that most people don't and
that's what he did the last time he was
able to find things that a lot of people
great students of this whole thing like
Devon Nunez who's who deserves a medal
and meadows and and Jim Jordan and all
these guys the way they Biggs and you
know every one of them they worked so
hard they worked it's just you know they
just couldn't stand what was happening
in the country they knew what was going
on the biggest problem with a mother
report he didn't mention any of this he
didn't mention straw and page and mccabe
and call me and the lies and the leaks
and the overthrow and the whole thing
with the hillary clinton got a win a
hundred million to one two lovers two
six lovers especially the one but i mean
these were like like children and their
FBI people the top people in the FBI i'm
so embarrassed for the FBI when you look
at it but this was he didn't mention the
insurance policy it's a very very sad
thing and it can be cleared up
incredibly well but you know you know
and so do i that without if you didn't
go any further there are tremendous
problems i'm trying to be very nice and
i want to be very tempered but there are
tremendous problems on the other side of
you had no other information other than
what you have right now tremendous
problems on the other side but why
didn't they mention in the Muller report
all of the the horrible things that we
found out about the other side including
the fake dossier the fake dossier which
even the New York Times now says was
fake which again I respect that they
came out and said it this is too big a
deal for mainstream media to give up but
the nice part is as far as Trump is
concerned and the trumpet ministry
there's no collusion and there's no
obstruction now it's time to look at the
other side mr. president if in fact the
New York Times is right in a dossier was
a disinformation campaign by Russia that
would mean as Bruce or testified behind
closed doors that he even told every and
by the way I agree with you about the
FBI the 99% are good people and this is
only a few at the top but if if they in
fact use that dossier as the bulk of
information and it's disinformation to
use the New York Times words from Russia
that Hillary Clinton the opposition
party candidate paid for that they never
fully informed the FISA judges of and
the Grassley gram memo Nunez memo right
that means everybody that signed off on
that on those four FISA applications
that would be that would be the first
one Jim Comey that would be Sally Yates
Ponte and rod Rosen Stein that means
they never verified what they told that
court I would say that's a fraud on the
FISA Court what do you say well from
what I understand it all being a very
big pile of trouble
that's the way I look at it and that's
the way I hear they'd be in a very big
amount of trouble it would be a terrible
thing if that's the case and you know
they've been denying that and they
started blaming all sorts of people
Papadopoulos who nobody knew and Carter
page who I actually feel very sorry for
I never met him but you know they made
him they used him to try and get to try
and spy on the campaign you know they
went in and these two guys were put on
councils having to do with the you know
various things what difference does it
make but they were put on two Foreign
Relations councils and with a large
number of other people and as soon as
people saw their name even though I
didn't meet Carter page and Papadopoulos
I actually sat at a table with him for
about 15 minutes and that was it I don't
I never spoke to him Ernie fake and they
were you know they've suffered a lot
like I don't
that they were not foolish because you
know they the way it all happened was so
crazy but they were hit like very few
people have ever been hit and that was
really to get to me
that was get to get to the campaign they
started using them in order to spy on
our campaign it would look like I bet
again it'll come out at some point so I
don't want to be the one to say but it
seems to be to me it seems to be pretty
obvious when you look at what happened
with Carter page and it's they were
spying the Attorney General said it
better than anybody the other day when
he was as yes I think they were spying
on the Trump campaign you can't say it
any better than that
I think so too mr. president I'm good I
have to ask you about the the new Green
Deal Biden and media but a one last last
question will you declassify the FISA
applications gang of eight material
those 302s well you know what we call in
this program the bucket of five yes
everything is going to be declassified
and more much more than what you just
mentioned it'll all be declassified and
I'm glad I waited because I thought that
maybe they would obstruct if I did it
early and I think I was right so I'm
glad I waited and now the Attorney
General can take a look a very strong
look at whatever it is but it will be
declassified and more than what you just
mentioned mr. president were now in the
election season and Joe Biden made his
big announcement today I thought it was
a very warm welcome you made for him on
Twitter which I read at the beginning of
the show here tonight generally your
thoughts on him his entry into the race
yeah Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
robert Francis O'Rourke your reaction to
the well now a record number is slated
20 people that would like to take you on
in 2020 well I don't know who it's gonna
be maybe Sanders or maybe Biden I think
that you know when you look at Joe I've
known Joe over the years he's not the
brightest light bulb in the group I
don't think but he has a name that they
know he is you know coming on with some
little cute statements about me that he
talked about the way the world is today
well I'll tell you the way the world is
today
we have a strong military we have choice
for our veterans they have choice now
instead of waiting online all day long
all week long all month long they have
choice they can go out to a private
doctor we pay the bill and they don't
have to die waiting online we have the
biggest tax cut in the history of our
country we have gotten rid of the
individual mandate we've had the biggest
cut in regulations which is one of the
things creating all of these great jobs
because we have the best unemployment
numbers that we've ever had today we
have the most people working literally
today
just came out we have the most people
working that we've ever had in the
history of our country almost a hundred
and sixty million people are working
their jobs and it's incredible so you
know that's really where we are today we
have we've rebuilt the military we've
ordered jets the likes of which no
country has we have fighter jets the
f-35 the f-18 we have jets the likes of
which no country has at all we're
ordering great great ships and boats and
aircraft carriers and they're all being
built in the United States that's jobs
it's all being built right here best
equipment in the world best missiles and
the way we don't want to use them but if
we have to with that nobody has what we
have nobody has our military nobody's
even closer when I came in we had a
depleted military we had an economy that
was going down you remember the numbers
they were terrible and they were going
down we were going to be a negative
numbers very soon and now we have
numbers that are incredible the economy
is esthetic records when it when foreign
leaders come in to see me Sean they
always say thank you and it's great to
meet you sir and congratulations on your
economy it's the greatest economy
anywhere in the world which it is nobody
is even close to us and that's because
of the things we've done so when Biden
makes the statement talking about the
soul I mean the soul take a look at the
Obama you know I heard somebody say
before that there was such
dissension and division people forget
there was tremendous division during the
Obama administration tremendous division
we actually have great spirit right now
and you know just to finish that off we
are a country respected again we are
respected all over the world they all
respect us even today
I see where President Putin in Russia
made the statement that it's great to be
able to help us with Kim jong-un and
North Korea we want to get rid of the
nuclear weapons we all have to get
Russia has to get rid of him and China
has to get rid of and by the way China
president she's been a great help we're
working on a big trade deal but he's
been a great help at the border and I'm
talking about the border between North
Korea and China and you know a lot of
good things are happening we're
respected again throughout the world and
that's a great thing well in Biden's
case in particular he's going to run on
his economic record versus yours his
position on Iran and Israel at North
Korea versus yours but generally
speaking we have not just congresswoman
Acacio Cortez about a hundred House
Senate members at least and many of the
Democratic presidential candidates for
2020 have bought into the new Green Deal
everything's free no oil no gas if
comrade de Blasio has added no steel
buildings or glass buildings in New York
and five years but more importantly
airplanes are gone combustion engines
gone how do you react if this is the
policies that you will be running
against well it's interesting because
they just heard about this crazy deal in
New York City where they want to build
concrete buildings that little tiny
windows and you know I've built a lot of
buildings shown I can tell you the
bigger the window the better I did with
it
people who have big windows and now
they're going to take them down to
nothing now the whole thing is crazy and
the new Green Deal okay and it's it's
it's got to be some kind of a joke it's
got to be they have to be kidding but
you know I saw the senator from Hawaii
who was so nasty to judge Kavanaugh and
that's another thing will soon have
within a third about too much 145
brand-new
federal judges and two Supreme Court
judges but she was so nasty to now judge
justice Cavanaugh so horrible and they
asked her about it the the new green
deal they said how about that and she
goes well I'm on Hawaii and I understand
they won't allow airplanes and she said
it's hard for me but I'll approve it
anyway even though there's no way they
get somebody said they'll build a train
to Hawaii now it's a crazy thing and I
can't believe they're really serious but
I hope we get a chance to run against it
I hope they don't decimate it sometimes
I almost wish I didn't say as much as
I've said to you about it because I want
that to go through and I want to run
against it I don't think they're gonna
win anyway but they're sure as hell not
get a win with with that legislation
never gonna happen anyway from a
practical standpoint obviously but it is
amazing to see the senator as I said it
is that I've known for a long time
distinguished Democrats and they're
falling behind her she's talking about
the deal that I don't know if they're
kidding I don't know if they're
desperate for votes or I don't know if
they're incompetent but they're sitting
behind her and they're acting like they
actually agree with what she's saying
about fuel and and and cows and all of
the things I mean it's a ridiculous
situation so I just hope it keeps going
I hope nobody criticizes it too badly
and I've already done too much tonight
because maybe I would have talked him
out of it that would have been a very
bad thing okay you don't want to do that
we had an incident this week I want to
go to the issue of the borders obviously
a defining issue for you and right
Congress was unable to override your
emergency declaration the Pentagon I had
identified I believe the figure was nine
billion dollars of unused monies and
that you were going to apply that to the
wall then we had the incident this week
where we had some people cross our
border and literally you know took one
of our guys guns you put out a tweet
better not happen again what's the
latest with both the wall what's the
latest on that situation
and what is the I don't know if you
heard about this contractor that said he
can build the whole wall for a lot
cheaper than anybody else and get it
done by 2020 you aware of that yes I am
we're dealing with him actually it's
Fisher comes from North Dakota
recommended strongly by a great new
senator as you know Kevin Cramer
and they're real but they've been
bidding and so far they haven't been
meeting the bids I thought they would
but what we get them for a bit we're
building many sections of wall right now
that's under construction right now and
I intend to have by the end of next year
over 400 miles of wall we've renovated a
lot of wall already a lot of the wall
was you know good at this stuff that's
what I do
and we renovated a lot we had wall that
was falling down but structurally strong
or can be strong so we saved a lot of
money it was we renovated we fixed it
and it's much quicker and frankly much
less expensive so we've renovated a lot
we built a lot we built a lot of new
wall in some cases we've ripped old wall
down because it was in too bad a shape
and we built brand new wall but we're
building a lot of sections and actually
over the next 2-3 weeks we're giving out
a lot of different sections they'll be
building it in different areas by
different contractors a similar design
and a really good design and you have
the Model T much more beautiful and
actually stronger let me the Washington
Times let me go to the issue of media
and New York that I'm sorry the
Washington Post New York Times received
Pulitzers for their quote coverage of
the Russian probe you've seen the the
coverage over two-plus years Russia
Russia Russia Trump Trump Trump
collusion collusion collusion Muller
report couldn't be any more clear on the
issue specifically do you think the news
media in this country and their coverage
on this owes you an apology well I do
owe me an apology a big one they owe you
an apology and all of the people that
you mentioned previously and
we actually had a lot of support I mean
I watch you and Tucker and I watch Laura
and you're great guys in the morning
with Steven and Ainsley and Brian Brian
came a long way I kid him but he came a
long way and and so many other people
not only on Fox
in all fairness but you look at Jesse's
been so great and I mean just so many
people but we had really a lot of
support including including as you would
say the Washington Times and some others
but the generally speaking it's corrupt
reporting generally speaking it was fake
news and a term that you know I'm very
proud of somebody said which is your
best of the names I don't know maybe
fake news who knows what it is now they
use it you know they use it to describe
something they think they get out of it
by using it then they're tricky people
but they were fake they were corrupt and
if they could change I would be the
first one to say I respect the fact that
you change but if they don't change
they've lost all credibility if you read
the stories that they wrote about the
Russia witch hunt and by the way guys
like Dan bond Gino and Greg Jarrod and
and justice Jeanine how about judge
Jeanine whose mother just died today
which is unfair just spoke to her she's
a great woman who loved her mother more
than anybody other than her beautiful
children but I mean she loved her mother
she was a great daughter and you know
she's going through a hard time but how
about how about Janine and I mean it's
been it's been incredible we have far
more support than people understand if
we didn't I wouldn't even be talking to
you right now I mean it would be a total
mess we had enough to fight the deep
state we had enough to fight a corrupt
media mainstream media I mean NBC I
think was worse frankly I think NBC is
more corrupt than CNN if that's possible
and I made them a lot of money with The
Apprentice can you believe it I was on
that thing twelve years with the
apprentice they wanted to sign me for
three or four more years they came up to
my office I said
running for president they tried to talk
me out of it I figured at least they
would give me for whatever reason they
would give me great but they were I
think they were more hostile frankly
than CNN which is hard to believe but
just think horrible stuff nobody can
believe how dishonest they've been you
know mr. president I've known you
personally for well over two decades and
by the way I don't think the fake news
brand is going away but on all the
issues you ran on conservative
originalist constitutional justices tax
cuts deregulation Israel Iran a tougher
foreign policy the wall we're now energy
independent for the first time and I
think 70 75 years and we're now a net
exporter of energy the one thing
Republicans ebowley you've gotten part
of it done and that was the individual
mandate right and you ought to take on
health care Mitch McConnell said not
this year well he's gonna be great what
we're going to do mitch is doing a very
good job we really work he's got a
passion for the courts and a passion for
judges we've worked great on that and
we'll be really good with health care I
mean we want to have we're gonna we're
gonna do things that nobody's ever seen
on health care but we have to get back
to the house in order to do we have to
take back the house if we don't take
back the house so we have we have a
problem you're never going to have good
health care because Obamacare is a
disaster it's too expensive not working
and we had it done it was done and then
John McCain at the very last moment late
in the evening went thumbs down and
everybody said what was that John McCain
went thumbs down he did a Republican
Party a tremendous disservice and he did
the nation a tremendous disservice
tremendous and it's unfortunate but we
had it done and had we known he was good
at because he said he was voting for it
all day long had we known that he was
going to vote against it I think we
could have convinced one of the other
two people that voted against it we
could have convinced him I feel
confident to go for it but we didn't
even try because we knew we had John
McCain we had everybody we're all set
and he went thumbs
at the very last moment and I thought it
was a disgraceful thing to do and very
very bad for our country and bad for
health care but we're going to do
something that will be great we have to
get the house back it'll be much better
than Obamacare and don't forget they
want to take a hundred and eighty
million private insurance plans away
people a hundred and eighty million
people are going to be stripped of their
great insurance that they have right now
because we've made great insurance
available to people but mama care is
actually it's very important but it's
actually a small part we have a very big
case in court and I think eventually the
Democrats and Republicans would come
together but we have a fantastic plan
that we'll be rolling out and it's
subject to us winning back the house
keeping the presidency which I think
we're going to do and also obviously
winning the Senate and as you know in 18
we picked up seats in the Senate but
nobody ever gives us credit for that we
won the governorship some many states
including Ohio and Georgia and Florida
and we had you know just great we were
at 53 to 47 nobody talks about that we
had actually a very successful we really
did we really had a very successful 18
election and they just don't forget the
Senate that approves the judges that
approves nominees but it approves most
importantly perhaps the judges mr.
president in this whole investigative
process you never invoked executive
privilege you handed over every document
you told your staff to cooperate that's
fairly unprecedented and yeah everybody
knows that you said it was a witch hunt
pretty often you said you were you
innocent no collusion the whole time and
you talked about off why don't you be
fired
you know muller or rosen Stein whoever
happened to be but you had the authority
under article 2 according Alan
Dershowitz and other lawyers but that's
a separate issue
you never did those things and I guess
my question is when you said this week
you will now fight all subpoenas and
enough cooperating can you expand on
what you meant is is enough I could have
fired everybody but under Lorna quill -
I
wanted to have transferred the article
to I could have fired everybody I could
have fired Muller I could have fired
anybody that I wanted to fire article
two I fired nobody other than kill me
and they're very interesting and that
was early and people don't talk about
that but the very interesting thing
about firing Comey is that everybody
wanted him fired all the Democrats I
mean virtually everybody the Democrats
thought he was horrible the Republicans
thought he was horrible and I said you
know this is gonna be wonderful I'm
gonna fire this guy when he gets fired I
think it would be popular I thought it
was gonna be a bipartisan firing when
and he got fired and the Democrats sat
back and they thought and the same
people that two days earlier we're
saying how horribly was worse ago this
is a terrible thing it's it's what's a
terrible thing is that not putting our
country first and I would I have been
the most transparent president in
history I said let anybody speak the
White House Counsel can go speak
everybody I heard I mean this is
incredible but I heard they interviewed
500 people I didn't know we had that
many people between the White House and
other branches I mean who would think
they interviewed 500 people if that is
possible to be correct
they spent as I told you thirty-five
billion dollars they had unlimited human
resources they had the FBI working for
him they had US attorneys they had the
Justice Department working for and they
found no collusion but I was totally
transparent I didn't tell anybody you
can't go in and I could have I could
have said you're not gonna testify
nobody is gonna testify when I say it
they do what I say
I could have said that but what happened
Sean is I wanted to be totally
transparent so then we get no collusion
no obstruction and then the house starts
now we're going to go and we're going to
go further and I said we've had it
that's enough mr. president only for the
constraints of time I'd love to ask you
in detail about all these candidates how
about one word description on some of
the top candidates in for 2020 like for
example if I say the word Joe Biden
one or two words well I think we're
calling him sleepy joke because I've
known him for a while and he's a pretty
sleepy guy he's not going to be able to
deal with the president she I will tell
you that's a different level of energy
and frankly intelligence so I sort of
refer to Miss Lee P Jo because a lot of
people wanted me to change the word
sleepy to something else that rhymes
with it does that make sense to you and
I said I guess yeah into the race I'll
see if the starting games doc he's not
going to be able to do the job what
about Bernie Sanders boys got a lot of
energy but he's got misguided energy and
he's done very poorly in terms of the
Senate he said very little legislation I
think he talks a lot does he get it done
robert francis o'rourke well it's a
fluke
ted cruz did a good job I helped them a
lot in Texas we went down had a couple
of massive rallies and the people of
Texas are incredible they figured it all
out he's fading very fast I think he is
fading very very fast it looks like he's
going to be a thing of the past pretty
soon but he was he was a hot item for a
little while show you how dishonest the
press was I went down to El Paso we did
a tremendous rally I guess we had 35,000
people between inside and out at least
and he had 502 people and the press said
they both had big rallies they both had
bigger I said women one has close to
40,000 people one has 500 people and
they were very much compared but that's
the way the media is but and that's why
people don't like the media they've got
they've got it straighten it out because
otherwise it's not free press but he is
fading fast there's no question about it
all right we have about a minute left
less than a minute
mayor peak Kamala Harris well I don't I
don't see either of them I think she's
got a little bit of a nasty whip but bet
that might be it
and mayor Peters not going to make it I
would hope he would I hope I'm rooting
for him but he's not going to make it
all right mr. president you've been very
generous once again with your time
I think it's important sometimes I know
when you do other interviews that people
want to play gotcha fight and they have
their own agenda but every once in a
while I think it's important for the
American people to hear you in in answer
in your own words at length on some
important issues we do appreciate you
coming on and giving so much time to
this audience in particular thank you
thank you very much thank you Sean